let's talk about how to decide what to
do next in your career
welcome back to episode 15 of Udacity
career tips my name is Martin McGovern
and today we're answering the question
of what should I do next in my career
now I don't know who you are what your
circumstances are invisible person
watching this video but from the
comments that I've received and the
direct messages that I've gotten in my
inbox it seems that this is a question
that is on a lot of your minds and I get
it
when it comes to your career the world
is your oyster you can do this you can
do that you can live here you can live
there you could throw it all out the
window and start fresh or you could try
to find a new role within your current
company but that is exactly the problem
when we can do anything we typically do
nothing it's something called analysis
paralysis and it's the same thing that
happens when you're walking down the
toothpaste aisle in the store and trying
to compare all the different features on
each tube do you want tartar control
whitening fluoride charcoal whatever
that does if you actually sat down and
put together a chart of all your
toothpaste options you would never be
able to make a decision which is why
most of us go with the same old
toothpaste that we grew up with the same
goes for your career except if you go
back to the same old role that brought
you to watching this video in the first
place you'll be in just as much pain as
you were before so how do we decide what
to do next in our career how do we know
if what we're choosing is the right
decision the answer is you won't until
you make that decision everything is
just a story in your head you don't have
any real data points to go on and in my
opinion what's worse than making a
decision and then finding out it's wrong
and needing to fix it later is living in
a perpetual state of indecisiveness
where nothing changes and nothing
improves so trust yourself make a
decision and start moving forward you
will quickly learn if it was right or
wrong once you start doing it I'm sure
you have a lot of ideas of what you
could be doing next in your career
bouncing around in your head take the
time right now to pick one and write it
down in the comments so that we can
support each other and encourage each
other to explore that option until you
know if it was the right or wrong
decision if it was wrong we get to
delete it and never worry about that
career choice again if it was right we
get to continue down that path into work
that we enjoy doing so to answer your
question of what should I do next in my
career I say stop thinking and start
doing what you suspect might be the
right answer you'll find out soon enough
if it was right
thank you so much for watching if you
know anyone who's searching for a job
right now tag them in the comments and
let them know you're thinking about them
if you'd like more career resources
click the link in the description and
sign up for our monthly newsletter and
we look forward to bringing you more
tips to crush it in your career thanks
again and best of luck in your job
search